beachfront views and iconic attractions
draw more than 7 million tourists to the
Oceanside town of Santa Monica
California every year if you want to
stay in Santa Monica you can book a room
with a view at the Loews 4 455 a night
in early summer just before peak season
a bit further from the beach you can
lounge by the pool with the Viceroy for
350 staying in Santa Monica wasn't cheap
but around 2008 something started
happening in Santa Monica and other
vacation towns across the country belong
anywhere with a B&B over the next
several years more than 1,600 Airbnb
rentals popped up in the
eight-point-three square mile city of
Santa Monica with prices that easily
undercut most hotels in the area sure
you wouldn't get room service or freshly
cleaned robes but the seaside community
was suddenly more accessible to people
traveling on a budget and some Airbnb
hosts were raking in some serious cash
that was it about $400,000 in revenue in
my best old time year Scott Chuck bird
began renting his place on Airbnb after
he was laid off and was shocked so I had
much money he was bringing in he dove
headfirst into the short-term rental
business signing several year long
leases and putting them up on Airbnb he
even created a brand producing books and
podcasts about best practices for Airbnb
host we are entrepreneur the difference
between long-term rental apartments cost
and what the hotel down the street is
charging there's a huge gap there in a
lot of places around the world
things seem to be going well for Airbnb
years like Shatford and their customers
but that all came to an end in the
summer of 2016 the City Council made a
big decision about websites like Airbnb
in just a matter of seconds they claim
is consuming the city's scarce real
estate Santa Monica joined an
ever-expanding list of local and state
governments that had decided to crack
down on Home Sharing passing an
ordinance essentially banning short-term
rentals and forming a vacation rental
Enforcement Task Force the city deployed
its newly formed task force and ran a
sting operation against Shepherd
somebody at the city of Santa Monica
actually had a booklet property for my
four night minimum say $1,200
reservation just to get that rental
contract to be able to go to court
improve that of the short-term rental I
think they want to make an example on me
is because I was a bit more in the
public eye I was local against how I
thought that the regulation was unjust
how I thought that there was you know
potentially vimeos corruption and remedy
council officials with the city of Santa
Monica declined to interview requests
for this story records shows it in the
run-up to the Airbnb crackdown several
Santa Monica City Council members took
large campaign contributions from an
interest group that advocates for the
hotel industry an interest group that
happens to be run by a former city
council member others took money from
the city's powerful renters rights
interest group which believes Airbnb is
responsible for driving up rent after
the trial
Shatford paid his fine packed up and
left town for the more Airbnb friendly
cities Denver Colorado when my red toes
went away when I was treated the way it
kind of was by this booty I definitely
maybe just kind of think about what else
is out there what Scott is doing is
creating well he's bringing people into
the city of Santa Monica who are going
to spend money in the city what the city
of Santa Monica has done is destroyed
well they have attacked people for
making profits and they've driven out
people like Scott who found an
opportunity to really offer a service to
people that they otherwise wouldn't have
any
to have Christina Sandefur is a lawyer
with the Goldwater Institute in Arizona
a legal advocacy firm fighting to
protect the property rights of people
who rent out their home
she says the hostility towards home
sharing is growing in cities across the
United States home sharing is something
that is as old as our country it's a
centuries-old tradition people have been
opening their home to guests for
generations sometimes for in exchange
for money sometimes in exchange for
chores the disturbing trend however is
that because we've become so innovative
regulators now are deciding if they have
to shut down Home Sharing even though
it's been around for centuries on the
Island of Hawaii in Hawaii
you can be fined $10,000 for Home
Sharing bureaucrats in the islands of
Hawaii are going out to the beaches and
interrogating visitors Airbnb is at odds
with its own hometown San Francisco and
Anaheim have ordered Airbnb a task our
website for listings and turn homeowners
over to the police the entire state of
New York has not only outlawed Home
Sharing but made even advertising your
home on Airbnb or similar services a
crime probably the worst regulation that
I have seen is in Chicago
fiery hearing at City Hall today over
the new popular shared housing industry
Chicago technically allows Home Sharing
but only under the condition that you be
willing to share any information about
any guest who books your home at any
time for any reason without a warrant
so whenever a Chicago official decides
that he wants to come over my home
whether it be in the middle of the night
or on a weekend he can come in he
doesn't have to have a search warrant he
doesn't have to tell me what he's
looking for and he can do this every day
of the week if he wanted to that is the
most blatant privacy violation that I
have ever heard of back in Santa Monica
business is still booming for the big
hotels but by the city's own admission
the new regulations have outlawed more
than 80% of Airbnb rentals just a couple
miles south so budget travelers can
still book an Airbnb in the beach town
of that
at least for now live in Venice where
some residents say their communities are
being destroyed the American Hotel and
Lodging Association commissioned a study
and release the findings at a press
conference today
[Music]